ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. YOUR CURRY.
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHEN
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DALY DAVIES FLORA MIKE
FONG VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN. WILL
DONALD ANDERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH STONE TAMED BELLA
TEREZ VEHICLE TO OUR VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER. DAYS PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
USER. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL
. ALMIGHTY GOD. WE COME WITH
GRATEFUL HEARTS IN BECOME
THINKING YOU FIRST FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF COMING TO YOU AND
YOU HEARING OUR PRAYERS. WE
THANK YOU FOR TODAY WE THANK YOU
FOR THE SESSION AND FOR THIS
PLACE IN OUR STATE CAPITOL WHERE
WE ARE ASSEMBLED. WE THANK YOU
FOR THESE MEMBERS AND PRAY. THAT
YOU WILL TOUCH THEIR HEARTS AND
MINDS SO THAT THEY WILL BE
MINDFUL OF THE NEEDS OF OUR
STATE. HELP THEM TO STAND FIRMLY
UNDER BELIEVE. HELP THEM TO KEEP
THE STATE IN THE ONE. BUT OTHERS
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK TO FOR
GUIDANCE AND DIRECTION. HELP
THEM TO PROPOSED A KIND OF
LEGISLATION. THAT WILL INCREASE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME I MEAN. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AS SHE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
WALTER. PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE
SALUTE OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SPACE.
WHICH. ISRAEL. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAIRMAN
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM THE
AUDIBLE MARC LEVINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DENTISTS PRESIDING C.
REPORT OF A DESPERATE EFFORT
DAVID ON THE READING MISSION
AWARD MOVES AND MISTER FLORA
SECONDS. AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ. AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
WE ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
IMPRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. AND
MISTER WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SOMEONE
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM GRAY AND
QUIRK-SILVA TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW SOMEONE
MEMBERS BOERNER HORVATH WEBER
AND MYSELF TO HAVE THEIR
CHILDREN TO THEIR DEATHS TODAY.
AND TO ALLOW PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO ORDER AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
PATTERSON FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
SECOND READING FILE THE BILL IS
NON FISCAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT FLORA FROM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE TWENTY THREE VÌ Ã PULA FROM
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. AB
23-14 PETRIE-NORRIS FROM THE
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY COMMITTEE TO THE BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA FROM THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE TO THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTING. AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SIX LOW FROM THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED MCCARTY FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
IN THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY NINE. BONTA FROM THE LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
AND THEN BACK TO THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TO EIGHTY THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT KILEY
OTHER HEARING TODAY WHICH WILL
BE HELD AT TWO THIRTY PM OR UPON
GERMAN SESSION AT TEN TWENTY
ONE- STREET IN ROOM ELEVEN
HUNDRED. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. FINALLY
THERE IS A COMMITTEE REPORT AT
THE DOES RELATIVE TO AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE GRAYSON I
REQUEST AT THE REPORT BE EEMED
READ AND ADOPTED AND REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON TO
TAKE UP AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIRD
READING. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AVERAGE B. FOUR WE MOVED TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD HAS BEEN
JOINED AT HIS DESK. BY HIS
DAUGHTER BETTY WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY BETTER.
M. MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION THAT TODAY IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARIE WALDRON THIS
BIRTHDAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY THIS
WALGREENS. AND NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING. LOUGHERY
ASSEMBLY BILL. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVENTY
NINETY EIGHT SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOR
THE BEVERAGE TWENTY THREE TO
THREE WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY
SIXTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR THE
MEMBERS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FIVE
THE MINUTES TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN WITH A MINUTES.
TWENTY FORTY EIGHT WITH A
MEMBERS AND SENATE BILL TWO OH
SEVEN WITH A MINUTES. ALL BILLS
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN SHALL BE CONTINUED. WE
ARE MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
THROUGH EIGHTEEN PASS TO RETAIN
THAT BRINGS US TO. FILE TEM
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO BY MISTER DALY. AND
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AN ACCOLADE
IN THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS. MR DALY
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
DELETES THE SUNSET DATE
AUTHORIZING COUNTIES TO USE THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK
METHOD FOR PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
. WE PASSED A BILL FIVE YEARS
AGO TO DO JUST THAT BUT IT HAD A
SUNSET. WITH THIS METHOD PUBLIC
ENTITIES WILL HAVE LOWER COSTS
AND LOWER RISKS WHEN BUILDING
COMPLEX PROJECTS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DALY.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE
OF.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GONNA PASS RETAIN
AND FALLON TWENTY THIS BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM. TWENTY ONE ACR.
ONE SIXTY ONE. BY MR LEAGUE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO TRANSGENDER
DAY OF VISIBILITY. MISS SURELY
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LGBT PLUS LGBTQ PLUS CAUCUS IN
PRESENTING THIS RESOLUTION TO
COMMEMORATE TRANSDEV HIS ABILITY
THERE ARE OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
TRANS GENDER NON CONFORMING OR
INTERSEX ALSO KNOWN AS TGI TGI
PEOPLE AND TJ WOMEN OF COLOR
INCLUDING SYLVIA RIVERA MISS
MAJOR AND MARSHA P. JOHNSON.
WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
CREATION OF THE MODERN GAY
RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN THE UNITED
STATES FROM THE NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE DO YOU LUNCH COUNTER
PROTESTS IN PHILADELPHIA TO THE
STONEWALL RIOTS OF NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE TGI PEOPLE HAVE
CONTRIBUTED AND CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ADVANCEMENT OF
EQUAL RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY AS
A RESULT OF DETERMINE ACTIVISM
AGASSI TGI PEOPLE NOW SERVE AS
COMMUNITY AND EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS WITH ANDY MUDRICK
BECOMING THE FIRST OPENLY
TRANSGENDER. JUDGE APPOINTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA BENCH JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO CIVIL RIGHTS VICTORIES
WON BY TGI ACTIVISTS HAVE
EXPANDED JUDICIAL RECOGNITION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS AND
WE'VE JUST BEGUN TO TEAR DOWN
SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS THAT
RESULTED FROM THE MANY YEARS OF
TRAGIC EXCLUSION BUT THROUGHOUT
THIS COUNTRY THESE RIGHTS ARE
UNDER ATTACK THEY'RE TARGETED
ANTI TRANS LEGISLATION. IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TGI PEOPLE HAVE
POWERFULLY ORGANIZED IN RESPONSE
TO THE HATRED TRANSPHOBIA AND
VIOLENCE DIRECTED TOWARDS OUR
COMMUNITY. WE RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE BY TGI ADVOCACY GROUPS AS
THEY CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
DIGNITY AND EQUAL RIGHTS
BUILDING COLLUSIVE AND HEALING
SPACES AND PROTECT AND DEFEND
THOSE WERE MOST MORAL. AS LOW
VERNE **** ONCE SAID IT IS IT
REVOLUTIONARY FOR ANY TRANS
PERSON TO CHOOSE TO BE SEEN AND
BE VISIBLE IN A WORLD THAT TELLS
US WE SHOULD NOT EXIST. TODAY WE
ARE FROM THAT WE BELIEVE AN
INHERENT VALUE OF EACH AND EVERY
RESIDENT CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
OUR TJ RESIDENTS WITHOUT
EXCEPTION BY COMMEMORATING TRANS
DAY OF VISIBILITY. ASK DR UP.
THANK YOU MISLI. MS PARA QUE HAN
YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS TO
SUPPORT AC **** ONE SIXTY ONE TO
CELEBRATE THE TRANSITIVE
VISIBILITY. IN JEWISH TEACHINGS
NOTHING CAN COME BEFORE
LIFESAVING CARE NOT THE SABBATH
NOT YOUNG PEOPLE OR NOT OTHERS
COMFORT ALL RELIGIOUS
OBLIGATIONS ARE DROPPED WHEN
ONE'S HEALTH IS THREATENED
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS FACE
HIGH RATES OF VIOLENCE SUICIDE
AND DISCRIMINATION AND THE
JEWISH FAITH TEACHES THAT WHEN
ONE'S LIFE IS AT RISK. WE MUST
STAND UP AND SO I STAND ON
BEHALF OF LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS TODAY. GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE ACCEPTED ACCEPTANCE IN CARE
ARE LIFESAVING FOR TRANS PEOPLE.
THESE PREJUDICES THAT WE KNOW
EXIST IN OUR COMMUNITY THREATEN
LIVES. IN ADDITION JEWISH LAW
HAS LOT HAS RECOGNIZED GENDER
AMBIGUITY AND FLUIDITY OVER MANY
CENTURIES. THE JEWISH TEXT OF
THE TOM AND DISCUSSES THE FIRST
HUMAN ADAM IS CONTAINING BOTH
MALE AND FEMALE GENDERS. THINGS
PUSH US FORWARDTHEY ASK US TO
CONTROL QUESTION THE IDEA OF THE
BINARY AS A TRADITIONAL VIEW OF
GENDER. RELIGION HAS LARGELY
BEEN WEAPONIZED TO TARGET OUR
LGBT Q. Q. COMMUNITY AND AT
TIMES THE TRANS COMMUNITY BUT I
RISE ON BEHALF OF LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS TO STAY THAT WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
TRANS COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND WE
SEE YOU TODAY AND WE STAND FOR
YOU. WE STAND FOR YOUR RIGHTS
AND THE ABILITY FOR YOU TO LIVE
IN DIGNITY WITH THE CARE THAT
YOU DESERVE. AS TRANSGENDER
ACTIVIST AND RABBI ABBY STEIN
SAYS THE MOST AFFECTED PATH TO
RESISTANCE IS WHEN THE
PERSECUTED IN WHICHEVER WAY IT
IS GATHER TO FIGHT BACK
TOGETHER. AND WE STAND WITH THIS
COMMUNITY BEING TRUE ALLIES IN
FIGHTING FOR THE RIGHTS THAT
THEY NEED FOR SAFETY. THIS DAY
MAKES ME PROUD TO BE A
CALIFORNIA IT MAKES ME PROUD TO
STAND ON THIS FLOOR TOGETHER TO.
CELEBRATE THE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY AND STRENGTH OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THAT WE AS A STATE
PROTECT TRANS PEOPLE AND THEIR
RIGHTS TO BE THEIR TRUE SELVES.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
RESPECT A HAND. THIS CRISTINA
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER EVERYTHING WE HAVE OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS AND THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF. ACR ONE SIXTY ONE
TRANSGENDER DAY OF VISIBILITY
AND THANK. MY COLLEAGUE FROM HIS
SENTENCE AFTER BEING IN THIS
BOARD. WE'VE BEEN CELEBRATING
THIS DAY SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT THE WORK HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR A LONG TIME AMERICANS
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS AND MEMBERS
. AS YOU MIGHT THE THIRTEENTH
ANNUAL TRANSGENDER DAY OF
VISIBILITY. REMEMBER THE WORK
THIS BODY HAS CARRIED OUT TO
MAKE THIS GREAT SAY TO BEGIN. A
BEACON OF HOPE FOR THE WORLD TO
LOOK AT BUT WE HAVE MUCH MORE
WORK TO DO AS WELL. WE ALSO
REMEMBER AND HONOR THE WORK
BEING DONE BY THE TRANS
COMMUNITY NOT JUST TODAY BUT
EVERY DAY TO BRING DIGNITY AND
EQUAL RIGHTS TO ALL THE BILL
INCLUDES A SPACES FOR ALL. LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE MONTANA'S THE
SETTING JUST RECENTLY THE
GOVERNOR AND GOVERNOR NISSAN
APPOINTED ANDY BY DRAKE AS THE
FIRST TRANS WOMEN JUDGE HERE IN
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT MAKING HISTORY. I ALSO
WANT TO LOOK HONOR OTHER LEADERS
WHO HAVE BEEN OUT THERE HELPING
TO SPREAD AWARENESS AND
SPEARHEAD EQUALITY FOR ALL.
INCLUDING SAFETY HOLIDAY FROM
THE CITY OF BECAUSE OF THAT I IN
MY DISTRICT. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SAFETY WAS MY A WOMAN
OF THE YEAR. BECAUSE AT AGE
FOURTEEN SHE PUBLICLY IDENTIFIED
AS A TRANSGENDER WOMAN STANDING
UP FOR IDENTITY AND RIGHTS AT A
YOUNG AGE AND SHE SAID THAT IF.
I NEED TO IDENTITY PERIOD.
BECAUSE OF OUR COURAGE AND
ADVOCACY THAT BY MY
ADMINISTRATION USE AROUND TOO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT POLICY
CHANGES. ALSO MODEL FOR FEDERAL
POLICY AND IMPLEMENTING GENDER
IDENTITY AND BATHROOM USE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. OR WE CAN NOW
COLLEGES ARE GENDER NEUTRAL
BATHROOMS. I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE JANET GOOD YET AS TO
ENTER AT THE PRESIDENT OBAMA
DURING A SPEECH CALLING FOR AN
END TO THE DEPORTATION OF LGBTQ
IMMIGRANTS. AND THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN FILMMAKER NOVEL MAU WHO
CREATES FILM DEPICTING HER
EXPERIENCES DATING AS A TRANS
LATINA WOMEN IN DEALING WITH
TRANSPHOBIA AND ISSUES AROUND
CONSENT. ORBAN IS ALSO THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT THE TRANS
LEADING COALITION IN LOS ANGELES
WHO IS ALSO THE CO FOUNDER OF
THE CENTER FOR VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ENTRANCES OR WELLNESS
AND ALLEN. THESE INDIVIDUALS
LIKE MANY IN THE PAST HAVE BEEN
RISING UP SPEAKING UP AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A QUALITY
EQUITY AND DIGNITY. FOR ALL OUT
THERE AND WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
FOR THEIR WORK. SOCIAL IDENTITY
MATTERS AND THEY ARE NOT IN TURN
INTANGIBLE CONCEPTS THAT WE MAY
SHY AWAY FROM IMPOLITE
CONVERSATIONS. AS A SOCIETY WE
MUST DO BETTER OR A BETTER JOB
OF CREATING SPACES FOR PEOPLE TO
BE FULLY EXPRESSIVE OF WHO THEY
ARE. CALIFORNIA PROVIDE SEPARATE
REFUGE OT JUST FROM OTHER
STATES WHO SEEM DETERMINED TO
THE NAY TRANSGENDER. GENDER NON
CONFORMING AND INTERSEX
COMMUNITY BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS BUT
OTHER NATIONS AS WELL. EMERG
INFECT FACING PROSECUTION FOR
IDENTITY FLOCKED TO CALIFORNIA
SEEKING THE PROTECTION OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE PROVIDES AND
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TODAY AND
EVERY DAY. ARE STANDING WITH OUR
TRANS COMMUNITY FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
MR LEE YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
JOINING IN THE CHORUS TO
REAFFIRM OUR STATE SUPPORT FOR
THE TRANS GENDER NON CONFORMING
AND INTERSEX COMMUNITY. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FOR
MANY IN THE COMMUNITY VISIBILITY
COMMUNITY INCREASE LIKELY TO
HARM LAST YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WAS THE DEADLIEST YEAR ON RECORD
FOR THAT OF TGI PEOPLE- LET IT
WAS THE DEADLIEST THE ON RECORD
FOR TJ PEOPLE INCLUDING. THE
LOSS OF NATALIA SMITH WHO IS
MURDERED IN MY HOMETOWN OF THE
**** AND FOR EACH TGI PERSON
KILLED OR LOST THIS YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE MOURN THEM
WE HONOR THEM AND WE SAY THEIR
NAMES. AMARI LASER. DUVALL
PRINCESS CYPRESS RAMEAU'S A. O.
ME SKINNER MATTHEWS SPENT A NO
SPAM PINNED PENNETTA. PULTE
PALOMA VASQUEZ AND TODAY TGI
COMMITTEE YOUR LIVES MATTER YOUR
STORIES MATTER AND WE WILL FIGHT
FOR YOU- ASKS THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU. THE GRISLY THE
AUTHORS ASKING THAT FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. COOPER ON THE RESOLUTION
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE THERE
ARE FORTY ONE CO AUTHORS AT A
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AC ARE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS. TWENTY TWO. AND
TWENTY THREE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
WE'RE GONNA PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
FIVE THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX. SB THREE
FORTY NINE. SEPARATE SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY NINE BY SENATOR-
BURKE AND OTHERS IN EQUITY THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IS PETRIE-NORRIS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER NUMBERS
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
SENATOR AND BERG'S SB THREE
FORTY NINE THE CALIFORNIA
ETHICAL TREATMENT FOR PERSONS
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER ACT
SB THREE FORTY NINE PROPOSES A
BILL OF RIGHTS FOR THOSE
RECEIVING TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE WHICH ENTITLES
THEM TO APPROPRIATE EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENTS PROVIDED BY
QUALIFIED CAREGIVERS IN A SAFE
AND ETHICAL SETTING. SB THREE
FORTY NINE ALSO REQUIRES
TREATMENT PROVIDERS MARKETING
AND ADVERTISING MATERIALS TO BE
COMPLETE ACCURATE AND EASY TO
UNDERSTAND CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
MANY HIGH QUALITY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS SB THREE FORTY NINE SIX
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO NEED
CARE FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
ARE ABLE TO GET THE CARE THIS
LIFESAVING PROGRAMS PROVIDE
INSTEAD OF BEING STEERED TO
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
PENSIONERS SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- ROSARIO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE BY MR
GRAYSON. AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE GRAYSON. CLICK RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
AND OTHERS IN EQUITY TO
TENNESSEE IN THE CLEARING YOUR
ZERO TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
. DESCRIPTION THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE WHICH WILL EXTEND EVICTION
PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS. WHO
HAVE FILED FOR EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH. SINCE THE RENT REALLY
PROGRAM LAUNCHED ONE YEAR AGO
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION IN
DELIVERING ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED AND AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOUSING. THE STATE
PROGRAM HAS DELIVERED OVER TWO
POINT FOUR SIX BILLION IN DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO DATE HELPING MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
PAY OFF RENTAL DEBT. AND AVOID
EVICTION ONE IN THREE PAYMENTS
NATIONALLY HAVE BEEN MADE IN
CALIFORNIA TO TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS INDEED. BUT IT IS
TAKING LONGER THAN EXPECTED FOR
THE STATE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS FOR COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
THOUSANDS CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
RELIEF WHILE THEIR APPLICATIONS
PENNED. IT WOULD BE CRUEL IT
WOULD BE WASTEFUL AND UNFAIR TO
SUBJECT CALIFORNIANS TO EVICTION
FOR THE LOSS OF RENTAL INCOME
NOW. WHEN THEY HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
ASKED AND ALSO THE DISTRIBUTION
OF THEIR RENT EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IS EMINENT. AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE WILL EXTEND
EVICTION PROTECTIONS THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE FILED
A COMPLETE APPLICATION BY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
EVEN AS CALIFORNIA RETURNS TO
PRE PANDEMIC LIFE AND THE
PROGRAM COMES TO AN END AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE WILL
HELP MAXIMIZE EVERY LAST
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
DOLLAR. TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES. THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON
MISSED WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES. AYE URGENT AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL AND YOU KNOW. I
KNOW THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT I
THINK WE KNOW THIS BILL IS NOT
PERFECT WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE EARLIER
TODAY ABOUT THIS. BUT THE TRUTH
OF THE MATTER IS WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE BRINK RIGHT NOW
WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE TO RECEIVE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. AND IF WE DO
NOT PASS THIS BILL TODAY THAT
THOSE PROMISES WILL NOT BE
HONORED SO WE NEED TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND PERFECT AS IT
MAY BE. AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU KNOW THE DEADLINE IS FAST
APPROACHING WE CAME UP WITH A
DEAL THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
THROUGH BOTH BODIES AND
HOPEFULLY SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD THAT WE CONTINUE TO
DO THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO.
AND HOUSING COMMITTEE AND OTHER
POLICY COMMITTEES AROUND
PROTECTING OUR RENTERS ENSURING
WEIGHT WHEN WE HAVE OUR HOUSING
SUPPLY ENSURING WE HAVE LOW
INCOME HOUSING. I FEAR THAT IF
WE DON'T MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A MASS WAVE
OF EVICTIONS AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SO IS THE PERFECT
OUT AS IT IS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WICKS MISTER GIPSON YOUR
REFERENCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL BEFORE US ARE ABSOLUTE
BELIEVE IS A THOUGHTFUL BUT IT'S
ALSO AGGRESSIVE WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WHO- FORTY SIX
PERCENT. OF MY DISTRICT ARE
RENTERS. 46% OVER A QUARTER OF A
MILLION PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT.
ARE RENTERS- AND EVEN THOUGH
THAT IT LOOKS LIKE MOST OF
CALIFORNIA IS TURNING A CORNER
NOT EVERYBODY IS TURNING THE
CORNER AND I BELIEVE THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY A THOUGHTFUL WAY FOR
US TO MOVE FOR TO HELP THOSE WHO
ARE STILL. ARE IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE BY- THEIR GOVERNMENT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU. HAS
EVER HAD OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND
THE NIGHT WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE I
CERTAINLY HAVE A MY DISTRICT. I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
EVER FACED. A SITUATION YOUR
LIFE TO CIRCUMSTANCES BEYOND
YOUR CONTROL WHO WERE YOUR HOME
YOUR DWELLING. WAS THREATENED-
IS NOT A COMFORTABLE FEELING. I
HEAR FROM MY CONSTITUENTS ALL
THE TIME IN THIS AREA IN THIS
AREA AND PEOPLE ARE SCARED.
PEOPLE ARE ABSOLUTELY SCARED AND
SO FOR ME I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ONE WE HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION. NO ONLY A
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION BUT WE
PUT SOME VERY- TEETH OR GRAYSON
IS TO HELPING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
STILL ABSOLUTELY IN NEED OF THE
KIND OF HELP THAT WE CAN RENDER
SO I WOULD SIMPLY ASK. EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU SEARCH YOUR
HEART YOUR SOUL AND ALSO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL- TWENTY ONE.
SEVENTY NINE AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS GREAT
MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK IS GIPSON
MR TANG. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
EXPERTS SPEAKER- I UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL- I DO NEED I DO WANT
TO JUST TAKE THE OFFER THANK OR
SPEAKER STAFF LIKE A PRO TEM
STAFF. FOR ALL THE INCREDIBLE
WORK OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE
GONNA BE HELPED. BY THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION BUT UNFORTUNATELY
AS PART OF THIS COMPROMISED
AGAIN WE DEAL WITH. IN PERFECT
LEGISLATION THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS PERFECT LEGISLATION
I'VE BEEN HERE ALMOST TEN YEARS.
NEVER VOTED ON A PERFECT BILL
EVEN OUR- BUDGET BILLS ARE NOT
PERFECT. BUT THIS BILL A
PARTICULAR HAS SOMETHING THAT I
JUST CAN'T ACCEPT WHICH IS A PRE
AMPS. OF THE CERTAIN LOCAL
ORDINANCES IN MY CITY- WE KNEW
THAT THE EVICTION WERE TORN WAS
ENDING ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST OUR
CITY AND COUNTY- PASSED ITS OWN
LAW TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE FIRST ON.
THE- FORTUNATELY THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION A PREEMPT THAT AND
SO OUR- CITY IS GOING TO BE
LOSING. THOSE PROTECTIONS THAT
WE HAD- FOUGHT HARD AND BILLY
SAW ON SO UNFORTUNATELY- CAN I
AM I RISE IN OPPOSITION AND I'VE
OF COURSE. WE CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
WHICH TANK MISTER LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE HARD WORK OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CONCORD AND FROM OAKLAND
FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL. YOU
KNOW THIS IS OF COURSE WHAT THE
FIFTH TIME THAT WE HAVE COME TO
THE BRINK AGAIN. FIGHTING FOR
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FRANKLY IT'S SOMETHING I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE STATE WOULD ADOPT
FROM MY HOME OR ONE OF MY
COUNTIES ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE WE
HAVE TIED. OUR RENTAL
PROJECTIONS TO THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE HAVE NOT AFFORDED
ON THAT TO THE STATE. AND I DO
ALSO SHARE MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERNS ABOUT LOCAL PREEMPTION
THOUGH I WILL BE SUPPORT HIS
BILL TODAY BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE
WHO NEED HELP RIGHT NOW I'VE
HEARD. PERSONALLY FROM SO MANY
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE AFRAID. WHO
ARE AFRAID THAT THEY WILL LOSE
THEIR HOME THE ROOF ABOVE THEIR
HEAD. AND THEY NEED TO HELP
IMMEDIATELY AND WE NEED TO DO
ALL WE CAN. TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG AND CURE NOW THERE ARE
PEOPLE WAITING FOR MONTHS YOU
HAVE BEEN APPROVED RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN THEIR MONEY.
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE STILL WHO
NEED TO APPLY YOU NEED TO GET IN
THE QUEUE SO WE NEED TO BE DOING
ALL WE CAN. THIS OF COURSE IS
NOT A PERFECT MEASURE AND I DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT TO BUT I DO
THINK. THE GOOD OUTWEIGHS THE
BAD IN THIS AND I WILL BE
VOTING. IN SUPPORT OF IT THANK
YOU. THANK THANK YOU ASHLEE. I
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
RESTORATION YOU MAY CLOSE YOU
WISH I APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
JOINT AUTHORS FROM OAKLAND AS
WELL AS THE SPEAKER HIS STAFFAND PRO TEM AND HER STAFF I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AND WITH
THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. SIX
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE URGENCY I SIXTY NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE MEDIA TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE
SENATE THERE READING FILE.
MOVING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SENATE BILL FIVE OH
FOUR. COOKERY SENATE BILL FIVE
OH FOUR VISOR BACKER AND
ACALANES REFLECTIONS IN THE
CLEAR THE AIR SEEDER OF TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MISTER BRIAN
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB FIVE OH FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR BAKER SB FIVE
OH FOR THE BIPARTISAN VOTER
REGISTRATION MEASURE SPONSORED
BY OUR STATE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
AND CLERKS IT HAS GONE OFF THE
FLOOR BEFORE THE ONLY REASON I
CAME BACK WITH A TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO REGISTER TO VOTE BY
MAIL PERMANENTLY CLAUSE BECAUSE
THAT IS NOW REDUNDANT IN OUR
STATE ELECTIONS- THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THIS BILL DOES
THAT MAKE SURE. THAT OUR
MILITARY OVERSEAS AND VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES CAN REGISTER
TO VOTE. FIFTEEN OR LESS DAYS
BEFORE AN ELECTION AGAIN THIS
BILL HAS HAD NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS MOVED OFF THE FLOOR BEFORE I
REQUEST WE ASK OUR VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRIME. MISTER FLORES
THE MISTAKE YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
SPOKE TO MR FLOOR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THE MISTER SPEAKER I
SPOKE TO THE CHAIR OF ELECTIONS
AND APPRECIATE YOU REACHING OUT
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU MEMBERS
ARE GOOD IT IS WE DONE THAT WE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BRING ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS FLORA. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE AND
MISTER BRIAN YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH RESPECT LESS RIVAL.
THANK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE AND TELL
YOU WHAT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ON THE MEASURE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
. TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR. DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CORKERY THE SECOND
DAY CONSECTETUER ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERCUNNINGHAM AN
ACT RELATING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THE CLUB IN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS THAT IS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF. IS THERE
DEVELOP. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON. THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT TWO
THIRTY PM. IN SWING SPACE ROOM
ELEVEN HUNDRED. AS
TRANSPORTATION AT TWO THIRTY IN
SWINGS SPACE ELEVEN HUNDRED.
BUDGET UB COMMITTEE ONE WILL
MEET AT TWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. IN THE BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL MEET
AT THREE THIRTY PM. IN ROOM.
FOR
FORTY FOUR.
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM CALL IS
STILL IN PLACE AT THIS TIME.
THE QUORUM CALL IS IN PLACE
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
SEATS AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
RETURN IN THE MEMORY.
EVERS THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF MR RONALD MAR
BETTER KNOWN AS RONNIE WHO
PASSED AWAY IN ANAHEIM
CALIFORNIA ON NOVEMBER. SIX
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. RONNIE MAHER
WAS BORN ON APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR IN TOLEDO
OHIO TO RUSSELL JOSEPH AND RUTH
ESTHER MAR. HE WAS
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS I SAID
AS RON OR RONNIE BY LOVED ONES
RON GRADUATED FROM TOLEDO'S
EDWARD DRUMMOND LIBBEY HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
AFTER GRADUATION RONNIE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA AND SETTLED IN
ANAHEIM. HIS DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION FROM CORTLAND
UNIVERSITY PREPARED HIM FOR HIS
ROLE AS A LEADER IN HIS
PROFESSION HIS PURPOSE DRIVEN
MANAGEMENT CAREER SPANNED
DECADES INCLUDING VISIT
POSITIONS WELL KNOWN AT.
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
DISNEYLAND AN AMERICAN AIRLINES
AS YOU KNOW AND BOTH OF THOSE
TYPES OF JOBS HIS CUSTOMER
SERVICE WAS AT THE TOP AN A PLUS
AND THAT'S WHAT MADE FRANTI SO
SPECIAL. HE WAS A WONDERFUL
LOVING AND PRINCIPLED MAN RON
RETIRED FROM AMERICAN AIRLINES
AND SPENT HIS RETIREMENT
ENJOYING QUALITY TIMES WITH
FRIENDS FAMILY AND ENJOYING LIFE
. AND EVEN THOUGH RONNIE HAD
SUFFERED WITH MANY HEALTH
CONDITIONS INCLUDING BEING ON
DIE OUT DIALYSIS AND LOSING HIS
EYESIGHT YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW
THAT AS HE WAS THE MOST
OPTIMISTIC HUMOROUS FUN LEVINE
OUT REACHING MAN THERE WAS.
RONNIE WAS ALSO A VERY LOVING
SON BROTHER UNCLE COUSIN AND A
WARM AND CARING FRIEND HE HAD
FRIENDS FROM COLLEGE HE HAD
FRIENDS FROM DISNEYLAND HE HAD
FRIENDS FROM THE NEIGHBORHOOD
PEOPLE LOVED RONNIE WITH HIS
HAWAIIAN SHIRTS AND HIS HATS
THAT HE WAS KNOWN FOR. HE LOOKED
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE EVEN FOR ME
KNOWING HIM FOR WELL OVER THREE
DECADES LOSING HIS EYESIGHT HE
STILL SAID SURE I CAN HELP YOU I
CAN HELP YOU ON YOUR CAMPAIGN
JUST GET SOMEBODY TO DIAL AND
ALL DO THE TALKING AND ANYBODY
WHO KNOWS RUNNY NOSE AT THAT WAS
A- SUPER BIG HELP. WITH THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAVE MISSED HIM
DEARLY AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
AND WITH OUR OFFICE WAS ABLE TO
HELP HIM IN THE VERY LAST DAYS
WITH A HOUSING ISSUE WHERE WE
WORKED WITH THE CITY OF ANAHEIM
TO KEEP IN THE HOUSE AS HE
RESTED AND IN THE END FINALLY
DIED BECAUSE OF SOME OF HIS
HIM HE LIVES BEHIND HIM. HIS
MOTHER RUTH MARC AND HIS
SIBLINGS RONNIE RODNEY MARC
JACKIE WEBB ROBIN MARK REXAHN
RACKS AND SHEER AND A HOST OF
LOVING NEPHEWS NIECES AND
EXTENDED FAMILY INCLUDING HIS
VERY SPECIAL FAMILY FROM THE
WEST COAST PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING CONDOLENCES TO THE MAHER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS FOR THEIR
LOSS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK-SILVA. AND MR CUNNINGHAM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISETODAY TO
ASK THE SOUTH THE GERMAN IN THE
MEMORY OF LARRY MORSE LARRY
MORRIS WAS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF MERCED COUNTY FOR TWELVE
YEARS AND THE VOICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. HE DIED SUDDENLY
LAST SEPTEMBER AT THE AGE OF
SIXTY FOUR LAYER WAS BORN IN
LANCASTER CALIFORNIA DOES
PARENTS LARRY SENIOR JUDGE AND
MOTHER SERRANO SCHOOL TEACHER
LARRY EVENTUALLY FOLLOWED IN HIS
FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS AND PURSUED A
CAREER IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. IN
HIGH SCHOOL THERE WAS A THREE
SPORT ATHLETE HE CARRIED THAT
PASSION THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. HE
ALWAYS ENSURED THAT LOCAL
CHILDREN WOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SPORTS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR FINANCIAL SITUATION.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL HE ATTENDED
THE UNIVERSITY OF ARKANSAS
EARNING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
JOURNALISM. HE EVENTUALLY WENT
ON AS A REPORTER TO COVER
GOVERNOR LATER PRESIDENT BILL
CLINTON WATERGATE IN THE SPACE
SHUTTLE LANDINGS. BUT THE REAL
HIGHLIGHT OF ARKANSAS CAME FROM
LITTLE ROCK WHERE HE MET THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE AND FUTURE WIFE
CINDY. LARIAN CINDY WERE MARRIED
HAD THREE SONS AND THEIR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS TOGETHER. AFTER
STANTON DC WORKING AS A PRESS
SECRETARY. VERY MOVE BACK HOME
TO CALIFORNIA. HE AND CINDY
ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY PACIFIC
MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. HE THEN SERVED IN
THE CAPITAL AS A COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS. TO BE CLOSER TO FAMILY
THEY MOVED TO MERCED. WERE LATER
JOINED THE DA'S OFFICE. HE WAS
ELECTED THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX WHICH WAS HIS
GREATEST SOURCE OF PROFESSIONAL
PRIDE. LARRY CONTINUED AS THE
ELECTED DA TO TRY HIGH PROFILE
MURDER CASES AS ELECTED DA HE
SUCCESSFULLY PROSECUTED ALMOST
TWENTY MURDER CASES THE MOST OF
ANY ELECTED DA IN THE STATE. HE
WAS THE VOICE OF CDA THE
CALIFORNIA DA'S ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO WORK WITH VERY SEVERAL
TIMES ON BILLS MY EARLY YEARS
AND THROUGHOUT MY TIME IN THIS
BUILDING. I MET HIM WHEN I WAS A
YOUNG DEPUTY DA INSENSIBLE
SUPPOSE SERVING ON A LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE WE BONDED INSTANTLY.
WE HAD SHARED INTERESTS IN TRIAL
WORK IN U. SPORTS AND POLITICS
AND OUR KIDS HE BECAME A MENTOR
AND A FRIEND AND HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENCOURAGING ME
TO SEEK OFFICE. SO MY MOST
CHERISHED MEMORIES. FROM MY TIME
HERE THE VOICE MAILS AND TEXT
LARRY WOULD SEND ME AFTER BILL
PRESENTATION- FORSPEECH. BEING
COMPLEMENTED BY LARRY ON
PERSUASIVE SPEAKING WAS LIKE
GETTING A COMPLIMENT FROM A
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL PLAYER ON
YOUR SWING. WHAT IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE CINDY'S TWO SONS.
GRANDDAUGHTER FIVES FIVE
SIBLINGS. WE'RE JOINED HERE BY
SOME OF THEM TODAY. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING THE
MEMORY OF LARRY MORSE. THANK YOU
MR CUNNINGHAM AND MR GRAY YOUR
TO ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE TWENTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THREE JR THE
MEMORY. OF THE CONSTITUENT. A
MENTOR AND A CLOSE FRIEND. I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN LUIS
OBISPO I KNOW HE HAD A UNIQUE
AND WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP WITH
LARRY. LET ME SHED A LITTLE
LOCAL PERSPECTIVE. ON TO HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN HIS LIFE.
LARRY LED AN ESTEEMED CAREER AS
A CALLOUS TOP PROSECUTOR.
IMPORTANTLY HE INITIATED THE
COUNTY'S VIOLENCE INTERRUPTION
OF PREVENTION EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAM. PROGRAM ON WHICH HE AND I
COLLABORATED CLOSELY
SUCCESSFULLY BRING A PILOT
PROJECT. AND FUNDING INTO THE
STATE BUDGET. AT THE SAME TIME
HE HAD PERSONALLY TRIED MORE
CASES WHILE SERVING AS THE
ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEY THAN
ANY OF HIS COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. HE WAS INCREDIBLY
HARD WORKING HE ALSO FOUNDED THE
COUNTY'S FIRST CRIME STOPPERS
PROGRAM AND BROUGHT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. BY
RELOCATING THE CURRENT DOWN NOT
TO RELOCATING TO THE CURRENT
DOWNTOWN LOCATION AND
IMPLEMENTING CUTTING EDGE
TECHNOLOGY TO TURN THE OFFICE
PAPERLESS. FOLLOWING HIS
SERVICES A PUBLIC OFFICIAL
LETTER WENT ON TO BE A HIGHLY
CAPABLE AND EFFECTIVE ADVOCATE
WORKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
COLLABORATING WITH LAWMAKERS.
AND STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. LEARN MORE SPECIFIC AND
PROFESSIONAL COMPLIMENTS ARE TO
NUMEROUS TO COVER TODAY BUT HIS
PRIDE AND JOY WAS REALLY HIS
FAMILY. TWO THREE BOYS DYLAN
ETHAN AND RYAN HE WAS THE CENTER
OF THE UNIVERSE THEY AND HIS
WIFE CINDY WHO'S JOINED US HERE
TODAY LOVED AND RIVARD REVERED
HIM. WHERE WOULD BE THE FIRST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT CINDY WAS THE
BEDROCK OF STRENGTH FOR THEIR
FAMILY DURING THE INCALCULABLE
LOSS OF THEIR SON ETHAN. AND
OTHER TRAGIC. LIFE EVENTS. LARRY
WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR MANY
THINGS LIKE HIS DEEP AND ABIDING
COMPASSION FOR OTHERS INCLUDING
THOSE HE WAS TASKED WITH
PROSECUTORS. IT'S LARGER THAN
LIFE PERSONALITY BOOMING LAUGH
HIS LOVE OF BOB DYLAN HIS
TENDENCY TO IMPULSE PURCHASE
GIFTS FOR FRIENDS AND- REYES
OFTEN UNSOLICITED ADVICE ON LIFE
LOVE CAREER AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
LANDSCAPING. LETTERS LOS IS FELT
DEEPLY EACH AND EVERY DAY IN
MERCED COUNTY AND BEYOND. BUT IS
VALUES AN EXAMPLE CONTINUE TO
LIVE ON IN THE COUNTLESS PEOPLE
HE BEFRIENDED MENTORED AND
INFLUENCE INCLUDING ME. I CAN
TRULY SAY I WOULDN'T BE HERE IN
THE POSITION I AM TODAY I
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE. MY
COMMUNITY AND THIS GREAT STATE
WITHOUT LARRY'S MENTORSHIP AND
FRIENDSHIP. ASK FOR THIS
INSTITUTION IN THE STATE TO
WHICH LARRY GAVE SO MUCH OF
HIMSELF REMEMBER HIS LEGACY
TODAY. AND ADJOURNMENTS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR GRAY THANK YOU
MISTER CUNNINGHAM ON BEHALF. OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM AND
GREAT. WE WANT TO WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY THE FAMILY IN THE
GALLERY THE FAMILY OF LARRY
MORSE WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DESTINY PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY NINTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH
THIRTIETH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY MARCH THIRTY FIRST. THE
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED THE RETAINED ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MR TANG MOVES MR COOLEY
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY. MARCH
THIRTY FIRST AT NINE AM AND THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
RANDY VOEPEL FILE ONE NINER BILL
ALFA BRAVO ONE NINER THREE TWO.
CHANGE IN VOTE HI DO NOT VOTING
. CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
ASSEMBLY BOTH NINETEEN THIRTY
TWO- TO NOT VOTING.